[Music]
from not marvel comes a film about a
sarcastic earthly and his fellow
guardians of the galaxy just not the
ones you were hoping for Green Lantern
you've already seen spider-man Iron Man
x-men The Dark Knight and Thor now
prepare for a movie that you would have
liked way better if those hadn't already
come out in this boring origin story
that was too nerdy for mainstream
America and too mainstream for nerdy
America Ryan Reynolds stars as maverick
pilot Hal Jordan a handsome
underachieving playboy kind of like Ryan
Reynolds when a magic ring transports
how into outer space he's forced to
become a member of the Green Lantern
Corps intergalactic space police who use
their rings to create anything they can
imagine like fists guns a high will scar
or a terrible CGI costume no it isn't
together along with a bunch of poorly
animated alien extras they will face off
against a universe full of deadly
threats like Hector Hammond a human
testicle and shrieks like a girl
[Music]
parallax uh slowly advancing space Bart
and a red guy who gets infected by the
color yellow no seriously it's the color
yellow gaze in wonder as this
thrill-seeking pilot is given the power
of human flight superhuman intelligence
and the ability to create whatever he
wants with his mind then doesn't seem to
give two shits about it actually quit so
spend two hours with three Van Wilder
his pants off
apply some planks as he turns one of the
most original comic books into one of
the least original comic book movies
featuring the same old cliches like a
science experiment gone wrong the theme
of responsibility the highest of honors
with great power the greatest
responsibilities comes great
responsibility a rushed training montage
never let your guard down boys mind your
surroundings a kidnapped love interest
let her go let her go and the same
traumatic early death of a father figure
as every other superhero movie ever
man fathers they must really suck for a
superhero starring Ryan Gosling
Blake deadly DC's other Brainiac Andy
Dufresne big and burnt Reynolds Green
Lantern they thought there was gonna be
a sequel that's adorable
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers I'm not bad I'm just drawn that
way I hate the whole plate the whole
plate release the Kraken
why so seriously in brightest day in
blackest night no evil shall escape my
sight let those who worship evils might
beware my power Green Lantern's light